- [Narrator] This is the
woman behind what is arguably
the most iconic theme song on television.
("I'll Be There For
You" by The Rembrandts)
But did you know that this
woman is also responsible
for some of the most iconic songs
on the radio in the last century?
- Biggest hits would be "September,"
- [Narrator] OK.
("September" by Earth, Wind & Fire)
- [Allee] "What Have I
Done To Deserve This,"
- [Narrator] Oh, that's a good one!
("What Have I Done To Deserve
This" by Pet Shop Boys)
("Stir It Up" by Patti LaBelle)
- [Allee] Stir It Up
from Beverly Hills Cop,
- [Narrator] That one, too?
- [Allee] "You're The
Best" from "Karate Kid,"
- [Narrator] I know that one!
- [Allee] The Color Purple musical.
- [Narrator] That's a lot of songs!
- I've written over a thousand songs.
- [Narrator] Jeez.
(electronic music)
(birds chirping)
(upbeat music)
- I'm Allee Willis.
I am a Songwriters Hall of Fame,
Grammy, Emmy, Tony,
and Webby award winning
and nominated songwriter, artist,
director, collector, art director,
social artist, party-thrower.
Most important one.
(upbeat music)
I don't know how to do anything.
I don't know how to play an
instrument, read or write music.
(maraca rattles)
(laughing)
I had seen less than five musicals
before I wrote "The Color Purple."
I'm best when I don't know what I'm doing.
- [Narrator] In that
case, she really must not
have known what she was
doing when she wrote
"I'll Be There For You," the
theme song for "Friends."
It went on to land her
an Emmy nomination--
- And we lost to the theme
from "Star Trek: Voyager."
I dare anyone to sing that now.
("Star Trek: Voyager" Main Title)
It's like, really?
Compared to the "Friends" theme?
But, that's how it goes.
("I'll Be There For
You" by The Rembrandts)
- [Narrator] Nevertheless,
"I'll Be There" For You
went down in pop culture history,
just like Allee's earlier big hit,
"September" by Earth, Wind & Fire.
- Do you remember the
21st night of September?
Love was changing the minds of pretenders,
while chasing the clouds away.
We very purposely wanted
to write a happy song,
and I don't think there's any
happier song than "September."
- The beginning of 1978,
I was on food stamps,
medical assistance, really
as close as you could be
to welfare without actually being on it.
By the end of the year I'd
sold 10 million records.
It was a surreal experience,
which my entire life is, so.
If I wasn't allowed to be creative,
I would shrivel up and die, I think.
Open the coffin, when
you throw me in there,
that's when I stop.
Though probably I'll still
be like, banging the sides,
hearing some kind of beat.
(ringing music)